[Music]
one of my favorite pitches actually is
of Prince George chatting to the queen
at princess Charlotte's christening and
he's pointing up looking at a hat who
knows what they're saying but it's just
a lovely moment what was it like when
Prince Philip was still here you know I
was so lucky to photograph Prince Philip
and the queen for their 73rd wedding
anniversary and then Prince Philip's
opening up a card from his
great-grandchildren you can see the
prince kind of lights that when he opens
the card They gave strength to each
other throughout their life and today
the queen will be reunited with her
prince for eternity I think that moment
where the Queen's coffin was lowered
down into the Royal Vault was very very
powerful what viewers may not realize is
that in that same Royal Vault currently
lying is the Duke of edinburgh's coffin
and they will both be interred together
at this private ceremony which won't be
televised she wanted that final journey
to be made with Philip by her side as
the Queen's coffin made its final
procession to Windsor Castle this
poignant image shows her Tony Emma and
the head groom saying a final goodbye
[Music]
also on hand her beloved corgis Sandy
and Mick Prince William assures fans
they will be well taken care of
today's celebration of life is also an
opportunity to look back at the Fun side
of the Queen Elizabeth had a wonderfully
wicked sense of humor and let it show
even getting both William and Harry to
crack a smile while in a military lineup
in 2012 the Queen's playful side was on
full display when she dropped into the
opening ceremony of the Olympic Games
with James Bond what's she like in
private is she very funny really very
funny wants to crack a joke and cracked
a joke about me
um we're having our photographs taken
and she just went oh no he's the one
that doesn't smile
she doubled down on her acting skills
putting on a lighthearted brilliant
performance alongside
and bear to celebrate her Platinum
Jubilee perhaps
he would like a marmalade sandwich
I always keep one for emergencies
so do I
I keep mine in here she didn't carry a
marmalade sandwich in her purse Darren
McGrady was Her Majesty's personal chef
for 11 years he reveals some Royal
secrets on his YouTube channel and his
cookbooks are available on the website
eating royally I remember my first
meeting actually it wasn't quite a
meeting I saw the queen coming towards
me with the corgis and then as we got
closer the dog saw me and then they
started barking and then all at once
they all started running towards me and
instead of calling them off the queen
just burst out laughing and I turned and
I just ran and then never got to meet
the queen that day
despite the Tiaras and crowns Darren
said Elizabeth's go-to breakfast was a
bowl of cereal and she wasn't against
eating out of good Tupperware and
despite dedicating her life to serving
the crown she never took herself too
seriously
oh really please
[Music]